voilà bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors tout
d'abord comment est-ce que vous analysez
cette volonté de twitter d'afficher ce
libellé le réseau social peut-il gagner
en transparence ou au contraire censure
est selon vous la transparence elle
n'existe que très moyennement on a une
une décision qui est pour le moins très
très particulière de de twitter qui me
paraît discriminatoire puisque comme
vous l'avez fort justement rappelé on a
simplement quelques médias affiliés donc
à la russie ou à la chine qui sont
aujourd'hui stigmatisés parce que c'est
bien ça dont on parle on a un traitement
différent de de la part de twitter par
rapport à 11,5 nos cinq pays donc
membres du conseil de sécurité
donc on voit très bien que tout ça est
ciblé pour le moment sur sur la chine et
la russie
donc non la transparence elle n'existe
pas et j'ai eu beau regarder toutes les
conditions générales de twitter encore
ce matin rien y figurent et à twitter
indique simplement qu'il ya un recours
qui pourrait être fait si le média
concerné ou la personne concernée ça
concerne également des des individus eux
qui peut être un porte parole un
diplomate ou une voix officielle d'un
d'un des pays concernés donc mais ce cet
appel on sait pas trop trop non plus
comment ça va ça va fonctionner donc oui
la neutralité de l'internet est
aujourd'hui bien mis à mal par cette
porte et de décision unilatérale de
twitter la chine et la russie deux pays
qui sont souvent accusés d'ingérence
dans des élections notamment les
élections américaines on sait qu'en
novembre les élections vont avoir lieu
est ce que vous pensez que twitter a
décidé de cette mesure justement en vue
du scrutin de novembre
oui c'était assez évident je crois que
twitter depuis depuis quelques temps on
réclame donc une contextualisations de
certains comptes bon moi ça ne me gêne
pas forcément par rapport à part rapport
pour que l'internaute puisse savoir
exactement de quelle de quelques courtes
il s'agit que rt françois indiqué comme
affiliée à la russie ne n'est pas
forcément gênant ce qui est très gênant
c'est la possibilité pour twitter
d'arrêter de promouvoir ses comptes et
même de limiter leur portée parce que
c'est ça la discrimination
en fait on twitter ne s'en n'est
absolument pas caché l'algorithme donc
qui de promotion des décomptes va être
fait de telle manière que les contes
dits affiliés ne vont plus être portée
et donc vont être mis un petit peu au
placard et donc on peut craindre
vraiment pour la liberté d'expression
dans ce cas là on a vu aussi une
certaine distinction sémantique qui
existent entre certains comptent
financer par des étapes pourquoi alors
c'est toute la question de savoir si on
a un média public ou un média d'état
ce n'est pas parce que un média est
financé par un parent pays et je prends
l'exemple par exemple de radio france
internationale rfi est un média qui est
financé par la france et qui a un rôle
d' influence sur notamment notamment
l'afrique ce n'est pas pour autant que
c'est un média d'état est donc temps les
journalistes de rfi sont extrêmement
jaloux de leur politique et éditoriale
et donc pourquoi discriminer
différemment rfi qui est considéré comme
étant une ligne éditoriale tout à fait
indépendante et rt france dont ont a
priori il y a absolument aucune aucune
raison de 2
de penser qu on a une politique qui
pourrait être dicté par un par un par un
état en l'occurrence la russie on a une
société qui est aujourd'hui une chaîne
française on a une affiliation au csa on
a des journalistes qu'ils ont des cartes
de presse française
bon pourquoi pourquoi de deux de base on
va déterminer et sur quels critères que
cette la politique éditoriale du d'une
chaîne ou d'un ou d'un média n'est pas
n'est pas indépendant c'est très
particulier alors effectivement j'ai
cité rfi on peut parler de la de la bbc
ou d'autres ou d'autres d'autres médias
donc c'est tout la distinction entre
médias publics médias médias media
l'état est ce qu'on en ait pour autant
sous influence lorsqu'on est un média d'
influence comme peut être fière défense
dernière question très rapidement tu y
arrives à laquelle sont aujourd'hui les
recours possibles
justement pour voilà dénoncé cette
décision mais écouter des recours déjà
twitter a indiqué qu' il avait notifié
leur décision à chaque achat compte donc
j'imagine que rt france ou a reçu une
notification comme quoi il est est
labellisée depuis le 6 août comme
affiliées à l'état
l état russe donc on a une possibilité
de recours direct enfin donc est
simplement une indication comme quoi
rt france réclame devrait donc les mêmes
droits de son compte que qu'auparavant
si ce droit n'était pas rétabli que
l'algorithme commencé à à discriminer il
y à l'article 10 de la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme sur la
liberté d'expression qui veut sans
pouvoir parfaitement être être utilisé
pour justement réclamé dans le cadre par
exemple d'un référé à paris sur par
rapport à twitter et je pense que des
actions juridiques sont tout à fait
possibles pour permettre une égalité et
un traitement équivalent entre entre
certains médias et d'autres dont il a
absolument aucune raison que twitter
s'arroge twitter ou d'autres réseaux
sociaux comme facebook s'arrogent le
droit de savoir quels médias aient ou
non dans la dans la bonne ligne et peut
être promue par par son réseau donc
voilà donc les recours existent alors
ventes seront ici une idée fait ça c'est
un autre un autre débat mais en tout cas
c'est une décidant de twitter très très
importante qui a été prise et que
ouvrant la boîte de pandore sur la
réflexion la libye
d'expression merci beaucoup tiré valade
avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat au barreau
aux barreaux de paris et spécialiste du
numérique